i guess this is like a chasing letter as
well isn't it yeah so the debts are like
a black cloud
that's super amazing that went really
bad it was like a one
shot man just overwhelmed i did think
that paul would be a bit further than
where we are already just like
banging our head against the wall do you
think
hardest one i've done man we basically
failed the financial freedom challenge
back to the drawing board you're looking
to buy some houses folks yeah
you might recognize jordan from the tv
yep onto the next one i don't know
manchester at all he's not doing any
deals in manchester before
i think this could be a little bit
harder than we bargained for these
agents
are not having it now that's a legal
what
when you ring they don't answer
when you go in they're rude
come on that was me thinking manchester
would be a friendly place it's falling
through
oh i'm excited about that sounds sweet
i'm getting a bit excited now
oh [ __ ] oh man
i just had someone crash into me on to
the next viewing
we're in the middle of a pandemic
everything's closed
we just had a car crash but nothing's
going to stop us can't stop work stuff
depth free to prioritize just filthy
rich
this is unlike any financial freedom
challenge i've ever done richard's no
good
homes for you no good let's try the next
place
this is going to be massive we've seen
so many zeros
i do see people attempting entering who
would come to this bungalow in the
middle of the night who needs to book a
viewing when you can just
turn back terrible a rebellious property
a little bit too well though mate
it's not the financial freedom challenge
it's the become a developer
from nothing challenge like this is the
dream
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a multi-millionaire i've just come from
buckinghamshire
to stay at this dude's house his name is
lawton
he's in a lot of debt he's stressed out
about money
he was just made redundant from his job
recently and i'm going to see him seven
days
if i can help him get rich
hey how you doing
how are you doing here all right
nice to see you thanks for letting me
come into your home hey you're welcome
mate you're welcome
i'm going to go on stage for a week and
leave you guys okay
oh right so where am i going to be
sleeping
you are upstairs i'll go get my duvet
yeah yeah
yeah yeah shoes back up okay
thank you so much for letting me come to
your house man oh you're welcome it's a
good place
thank you so this week we're going to be
getting
investment properties and doing a lot of
deals what what are you currently doing
what's your current sort of situation
where you're at
so i mean at the minute i'm selling and
i'm deal sourcing packing up deals
getting them sold
um i'm doing like one a month that's
good yeah it's not bad at all
so you're already doing deals great so
what do you need for me what do you what
are you
what's the what's the dream what's the
goal i mean the the
the big goal yeah is you know i want to
do big jobs i want to do big projects
like your castle i want to do big
landing
yeah okay cool wow this is going to be a
tough weekend
so you're already doing deals but you
want to move into big deals
yeah like development deals yeah i mean
i've got a couple of opportunities in
the pipeline
yeah so you know i have been working on
things slowly okay
and so that that is the direction i do
want to go
so you want this to be like a
development challenge for the week when
we try and get a development deal
it'd be nice if you did get it finished
off yeah so do you have do you have
money to invest
no any money at all no
so what what are you how are you okay so
you're you're dealing sourcing
to live yeah i mean the deals that i'm
selling
is one a month but i'm cold deal source
in that as well
okay so i'm making half of the the sale
so yeah
it's 1500 quid for for one for one deal
yeah but
you know i'm keeping made up of water
that's my main goal at the minute you
know since it got me redundant and i
needed to find a way to replace that
wage
yeah pay for my house pay for my living
okay
so you haven't got any money at all to
invest but you have been packaging and
selling deals
uh you've got no investor lister no so
how are we gonna fund if we find like
the perfect development opportunity this
week we're not only gonna have to find
the development deal but we're also to
have to find the investor for the
development deal
is that right yeah do you reckon that's
the best plan
just go because if we find a development
deal it's probably going to be a little
bit it's going to be
quite a long time away before it starts
giving cash flow the thing i'm thinking
is a lot of people come to me and they
want to do development
they say you know i want to be a
developer i want to buy a castle
and the thing is is it it's a bit of a
pipe dream
if you i mean do you currently own any
investment properties at all no
none okay so i mean i don't mean to
say this the wrong way but i'm just
thinking at the moment
you're making 1500 quid a month cody or
sourcing with no investor list
i think that before you start doing
development
i think you need to become financially
free and where are you at financially
right now like are you in a
decent place financially john truth
of course um no i'm not i'm not in a
good place
and
since i've got maybe running obviously
i've been trying to do these i've been
selling these deals one every month
keeping me above water but financially
no
i'm not in a good place with it
[Music]
when saying not in a good place like
have you got if you've got debts or
yeah yeah you know i do have debts
i've got you know a thousand pound
overdraft
there's a credit card debt as well so
that's like three and a half grand
when do you need to pay that bar do you
know
if i'm honest it's pretty soon because
they're chasing
okay like they're asking for your me
address and confirming it it causes
unnecessary stress on
you know on on rachel as well and like
for me
it's just always it's always there but i
try so hard to push it to the back
you know because i know i've still got
you know i still gotta get out there and
find
deals just to keep this just to have
food which i mean
yeah support my son so at a minute like
i didn't think i'd do that you know yeah
i think it makes me realize it like
when i say about mason you know because
you want to support him
yeah so we need four and a half grand
to be able to tear this up and and be
debt-free then
a couple rental rents would be enough to
be able to pay your mortgage
and get in a position where you've got
recurring money coming in without having
to
worry about making another sale which i
think we can do really fast
and then if we have time which i'm sure
we will
we can um we can try and find a
development deal for you
first day of the financial freedom
challenge so the plan is we're going to
go and get a
rent to rent yes i think we should go
for two renter rents we're not coming
back to this house
you won't be back to this house until we
have the key store rent to rent bro
that's the plan
rent to rent number one let's go
manchester we're coming for you
you don't know um yeah i don't think it
would be something that we could
accommodate so we've had one
call and we've had one appointment and
both of them
have gone terribly we don't deal with
anything like that
right yeah we don't really do that
landlords maybe
[Applause]
so it looks like we've been chewed up
and spat out from the center of
manchester
i thought manchester was going to be
great because i've heard really good
things about it my mom was born in
manchester lawton knows the area well i
know property well
but the problem is i don't know
manchester at all he's not done the
deals in manchester before
i don't know where to start to be honest
so i think this could be a little bit
harder than we bargained for so
bridgeford's no good
homes for you no good let's try the next
place
hey how's it going we've got a company
where we do um corporate let's
guaranteed rent to landlords i don't
know if that's something that you do at
the moment
the manchester agents don't like rent to
rent it's got to keep ringing
sorry please leave a message
when you ring they don't answer when you
go in
they're rude and there was me thinking
manchester would be a friendly place
i did think that would paul would be a
bit further than where we are already it
just seems like they won't even let us
in the door well
they won't even be like i couldn't have
a look around the property or exactly
but i thought london would be like this
and manchester will be easier
yeah yeah but it really isn't
back to the drawing board yeah there it
is yeah
i thought he said we weren't going to
come back today until we got a renter in
yeah well we have to be uh
like water fluid
back to the drawing board do you think
he's lying
upset with me it's depressing
being told no over and over again but if
you just see it like a nine to five job
like in in your mom and you might be
thinking oh man that was my seventh no
in the last hour
but if you just think well they're
probably gonna say no they must say yes
it's gonna keep bringing what's the big
deal
right it's not really that bad yeah yeah
but i think it's your listen this is
your challenge man i'm just here to help
so i get you don't want to spend the
whole week trying to get a rent to rent
and not get one
but we'll forget renderings with us
tonight because you're like done with
rent events right now i'm sick of them
a guy has messaged me with a development
opportunity
he's fallen out of bed because he can't
get the funds maybe we can get the funds
we could buy so you got you
you negotiated for 275 yeah you reckon
it needs about 20 grand spending on it
and then it'll be worth probably about
three to five but you reckon if it was
extended and everything and built upon
it might be worth about 400 because next
door sold for 400.
sounds good obviously we can't view it
today because it's late
but these properties that we're finding
these opportunities
some of them are little development
things why don't we just go drive by
them and have a look at from the outside
who needs to book a viewing when you can
just
turn up we've got people looking at us
and stuff
so this house 285 000 pounds
next door sold for 400 000 pounds
the only difference between this house
next door is next door
has been extended so if we
extend this
i've got the plans and stuff we can
knock this back
put another room here and another room
here
a little tiny development we're gonna
push we're gonna push over a hundred
thousand pound value
i'm soaking wet but this is worth it
because this
could work so this is actually like the
first time that
we've got enough well i've gotten a
little bit excited because i feel like
we're actually getting somewhere a
little bit i don't get wrong we didn't
even get into the property
for us to actually come and have a look
at it and physically look at
how we could add the value to it and now
we've seen it in person like it
it does make sense day two baby
so we've got a viewing today first
viewing launch launched
what situation with this this is a
rental rent yeah
potential events event yeah i mean we've
put the view in
uh told the agent that it's somewhere
where i'm looking to live
that's a bad move bro i know but my
thought behind it is that we couldn't
get in anywhere yesterday
and i'm just excited to view a property
and just spend some time with an agent
okay okay well let's see what happens
you can do the talking because i think
this is a bit awkward
yeah it's nice it's a big space
so with like rentals like this
do you do watch with corporate lights
so in terms of like sort of dealing with
landlords and doing like long
long term levels no
what it is i'm after i'm trying to find
like flats the greatest we mainly look
for houses
and we try and work with landlords on
like a long term level
and i don't know if that's something
that you
you guys do with your legs
it's not it's not so that it's a company
though yeah you've
put work cut people yeah things like
that yeah it's not something we do at
the moment now
no what's it like for writing a minute
are you really busy here with it
what about the houses around salford
because they're sort of like the ones
i'm really really interested in as well
they're going quickly and they're going
prices okay
so like say three three bedroom two
receptions in so
what you saw again for those who are
renting i've been funny
well i'm talking are you interested in
this yeah yeah no i'm interested in this
one as well yeah
for a rental for yourself yes i'm also
interested in other properties
as well but you won't be able to rent
this and then let it out to other people
no no i'm interested this one for myself
how do you think that went really bad
really bad
like how you feeling embarrassed
talk to me go go home get off yeah
before she comes out
that was like honestly i'm like
i just wanted the ground to swallow me
up but literally just i feel like i
can't even speak to ever again
yeah that was bad that's why it's so
important i think that
before we ever do rent event before we
book a viewing
we tell them it's company left
beforehand because otherwise that can
happen she was treating you like a
criminal wasn't when she found out your
corporate letter it was like you were
you know it was like you're a criminal
what do you think i just want to get off
before she comes out i don't wanna
i think it's just time to go
it was just bad
why did you say that you were gonna live
there yourself when
she she knew that you weren't telling
the truth and you knew that she knew but
you you still said it what what
i don't know i literally don't know i
just couldn't face her at all
let's go i've got another rent to rent
person to speak to
yeah we've seen somebody else talk about
rent to events aren't we
do we have to go and see him though
oh i don't know i don't know i think we
should go and see her
the last one and just push this last one
get our head back in the game and if and
just see what happens i'm still hopeful
if you are then i am that situation
was awkward that was terrible let's go
so this is your
your big break to get a rent event how
would it work
from your end so if we paid him a
guaranteed ranks
yeah that's four arguments hey gramps
and then presumably you charge him
we pay you yeah the rent and we just
have it
on the company and then you would charge
him
how would you want to do it if we did
manage to make it work in terms of if we
took it on
and then would you want to us to just
pay you the rent
and then us to then just deal with the
tenants a month we tend to
go back you're the company light and we
leave it down to you to do everything
yeah and we drop in occasionally for
like just double checks and stuff yeah
no it's really good it's the fact that
it's like in the area close to the
to the hospital and it's pretty much
newly refurbished
i'm
that was so good that was such a good
view so what did she say
so she basically just emailed me back
saying hi lot was great to meet you
today unfortunately the landlord has
another offer that's more attractive
which isn't great i will let you know if
anything comes up in the coming weeks
if anything else comes available i said
regards
that was like our one that was like a
one
shot man so what do you want to do
no i don't know me i just think
i just don't i just don't even see how
the whole thing's gonna
even see how the whole thing's gonna go
i just don't
yeah well we're still
you know we're not even halfway through
yet
but two days in i thought we'd get more
done
it's just really really hard with the
whole culvert the national lockdown
we can't get any agents can't even get
viewings we're just like
banging our head against the wall all
the time yeah
no i understand you feel
so what do you want to do i don't know
i'm not sure mate i'm not sure
i want to
i just feel like he's um
he's just not he just don't want to
carry on doing this
this is probably the hardest um hardest
one i've done man
turn the camera
listen i was in debt man all right i i
have problems okay
now you can worry about that but when
you worry about stuff you just manifest
it just broke
so what's the point why don't we focus
on the stuff that actually generates
money not costs money okay so like all
the bad debt all that
[ __ ] it off don't worry about it i'm not
saying ignore it i'm just saying stop
stressing about it
yeah because what's the worst that
happened the absolute worst is going to
happen
did they turn up at the door they're not
allowed to not doing covert 19.
will authorize that so that's logical
think about it completely
logically okay if that won't happen
so what happened okay but what might
happen is you can pick yourself up and
go out and find some deals for
selling investors by the end of the week
yeah no no
no no i completely agree with you
life changing literally life-changing
from the ground up
don't be serious
because i'll be as hard to use you want
me to be
because that's how i am because i listen
dude i like you i was
ridiculously hard on you in the
boardroom do you remember that yeah yeah
yeah of course i do take it
right so just just get out there and do
it man go out find some deals
you can find some deals tomorrow [ __ ]
and sell them get on facebook get on
social media do some videos sell them
well we've got two deals man if we sell
these two deals he's completely out of
debt
speak to speak some investors send me
the deals i'll send them out to my
mailing list now
oh i did we'll crack on with it right
now when alasdair was talking you looked
a little bit noticed at one point what
was happening what were you thinking
i don't know i think like the whole
experience is emotional
i mean it's hard work you know we
constantly
got this like pressure on like i feel
like there's constant pressure
throughout this
to start this challenge to to do well
you know to like
you know do is do as good as i can to
try and book in as many
points as i can to try and find as many
deals as i can and i feel like you know
even when somebody says like god you
know you just need to
suck it up and just carry on it's like
sometimes you just need to hear those
words
because you know you're doing a good job
because you're working you know you're
working hard you're making the calls
and like when he was sort of talking
about the stuff like
you've got to remember like most people
don't even talk about ditch i mean
yeah i don't think i've ever spoke about
it as much to anybody except for you
yeah so i mean like i won't tell anybody
i won't sell
family members i don't want anybody to
know when you made redundant did you
have savings
no never i've never had savings
so you just kind of used to have your
money coming from your job and then you
spend it yeah and then you got mad
redundant and then it was like
whoa gone it was like that that platform
that you stood upon all the time and
just been like pulled
but you were determined i mean you could
have got another job if you wanted to
yeah definitely could have got another
job i mean the job that i had was
like for me and let me just put it into
context so you understand like i didn't
finish school with like top grades you
know i'm a
plumbing engineer by trade and like
went to college to do all that work to
british gas for many years on the tools
and then decided i wanted to learn more
about the business side so i got into
account management at british gas
and then worked at this other job where
i was here and moved up into like a
senior account manager
role and then project management so for
me that was like i was leveling up
you know i was doing well and then i got
to like you know 40 grand
a year you know company car like for me
then that was like really really good
just because like nobody else like
within my family
had sort of done that yeah i mean like
you're like a success
yeah in my own right yeah yeah like no
one had
helps me like i've done it all myself
let's say you lost the house
is that really going to ruin your life i
mean no but i don't want
mason to see it yeah so that's the fear
yeah like i don't want him to see like
he doesn't he'd even he didn't know
i got maybe obviously not the tiny kid
but like it took him a while for him to
turn out to be and say
how did you still work at that company
i'm like no no daddy set his own company
daddy's got his own business so i mean
so like he
he never knew this is like my moment
yeah you know
there's no other time and i kind of used
the lockdown
you know the bad situation of the
lockdown to my advantage because i was
like
there's no other time to learn something
i was going to come out of lockdown with
a brand new skill
and i swore that to myself as soon as i
got off that call i got into your 365
and i thought because how long was the
first slot down like four weeks yeah
i was like i'm going to come out of this
and brand new person and then that was
literally the start
of the whole property stuff this is my
phone
i've got a message from alex there
saying any luck
and this is your phone
and people wanting to buy the deals off
you wow
thanks matt
[Music]
and they're not saying i'm interested
they're saying i want to reserve it
so of them is put one on two how are you
feeling
just overwhelmed
i've never cried at all
can i give
[Music]
done it is a nice one did you ever look
at the um
the outside of it and everything yeah
yeah it looks really good like it like
as samuel mentioned like
it's one of those properties where an
older couple have been there it's
you know the grass is like cut with
scissors you know what i mean it's like
really
it's really nice where do you live
where'd you live jimmy um
london are you a bit far out i was gonna
say if you're around
you know once you've once you've secured
this particular property if you're
around you could even come down and we
could meet up and stuff and we can show
you some of the other projects we're
working on
um but it just depends if you can get
here
oh [ __ ] oh man
i just had someone crash into me hold on
oh man oh my god
where did the where did the where did
the driver go i don't even know
he just smashed into the back of me
didn't i was he he just got off
oh my goodness did you see
did you see the guy that i didn't see
anything i felt it and then by the time
that we've pulled off
i just assumed that it stopped next to
us but he's not
oh jeez that's the last thing you want
on a freaking wet wednesday morning well
look i don't know what we can do if the
guy's not around
i'm just gonna have to call my insurance
and tell him what happened but
[ __ ] you hurt anything oh let's go
let's go as we crash the car and come
into the house
the house has we have to buy it now
it's just pure cash watch the hmo
investment isn't it you know what i like
about this property though
a lot i like that it's off market i like
that it would rent out really west in a
really good area there is a lot to do
95 grand for this isn't a bargain no
it's not
but it's gonna give a great return on
investment yeah i definitely think that
you could sell this
what do you think of that last house i
thought it was really good thank you so
much for showing us around
are you welcome that probably that we
just looked at needs a lot of work
if it was in good condition how well do
you think it would rent out
as a hmr i think it would go pretty much
straight away do yeah yeah
i think it's a good area yeah both for
students and for professionals as well
it's awesome
well let's um see if we can find an
investor for right yeah
and see what we can do but we'll give
you a call back yeah thank you so much
for your time as well
really appreciate it on to the next
viewing we're in the middle of a
pandemic
everything's closed we just had a car
crash
but nothing's gonna stop us can't stop
won't stop
right let's go this one is good
this one this one's really big as well
actually
this is probably one of the biggest ones
though wilmington is like a really shoot
in the area
so hmos obviously really work well there
so you'd manage this yourself
since this is like a vr hmr vr html yeah
definitely
so this moon looks like it's probably
one of the smaller ones
but you know what actually it's probably
just look small because these cupboards
are all built out
this is the actual wall so what we need
to do
is we need to measure it really just so
that we know
2.7 this is big
by 2.9 plenty so this room is fine
plenty
just this one's taken out so you're
gonna get three rooms up here
one room downstairs four room hmo yeah
it's on the market for 125.
yeah the agent said they'll accept 110.
once we lifted it up i reckon it'd be
worth about 140.
yeah definitely so what's let's just got
some great stairs
so this room is going to be so you've
got three rooms upstairs this room
is basically just going to be a a a
bedroom yeah and then
kitchen through here yeah what it's
going to forward and get this wrapped up
yeah good job master we love it good fun
so
basically you know that property we've
just seen that hmo yeah i sold it
no three and a half grand hang on that
isn't
that isn't the bungalow no the one that
we've just been to this morning
i sold it who did you sell it to it's an
investor i've been speaking to for the
past couple of days and i was telling
him
as soon as i found out about the
opportunity i booked it in to see it
this morning on purpose hang on a minute
though
we've also almost solved the bungalow
yeah so when that sold that would be
seven grand and then we've still got the
middles we want to do
so we're gonna we're gonna you're gonna
you're pretty much debt free now bro
that's great let's keep wrapping things
up
no no no yeah i don't want to celebrate
too much that we
don't yeah getting stuff done just got a
text on the phone
seven bags in the bank oh no
nice job both of them done both of them
sold straight away
why don't you just pay off your debt now
then you can pay off
that's good isn't it it is how do you
feel
that buzzing like absolutely made up
like i don't think it's really hit me
that's what i mean yeah like it's just
like a number in the account i'm just
like
it'll take some time no never never
you've never
never never seen so many zeros
that's what we can add to it yeah
exactly what's happening in your end
uh we are just trying to get the rest of
the day filled up okay
yeah what was our first viewing is it's
still half past eleven yeah so we've got
a
more a chill morning which i think is a
good thing how are you getting over that
saying that third deal so we've had
so i was planning on having a decent
night's sleep last night and go to bed
early
yeah and ended up having a couple more
calls booked in because i think people
were adding like pin cores and things
like that
and spoke to about three more people one
of them
is like really really interested like
she's really happy to go with it
just all she's trying to do is wait for
a builder to get back to this morning
to see if a builder wants a jv on
yeah yeah so basically one of the houses
that we've
sold has fallen through
it's been i know it just whose house
jimmy's house
did jimmy pull out or did the house fall
through the house fell through
what happened i think somebody else
would come in and put a better offering
oh i tried to have a conversation with
the agent but how much did jimmy pie
three and a half grand oh and we don't
really want to lose that
at all because that'll be a massive dent
in what we've already made so far
what do you reckon we do i think we
should propose to jimmy that
if he tells us exact criteria yeah and
we agree
a time frame yeah that i will fulfill it
i'll find him a replacement deal within
that time yeah
i think we need to offer him a refund as
well yeah
because if we say to him i know you just
paid us three and a half grand
yesterday but you know what that deal
that you paid just doing i've gone for
it's gone now but we're gonna keep your
money and find you another one it's a
i know he agreed i kind of agreed that
but it's like in the mickey i think
get give call him and i'll speak to him
this is the kind of stressful thing that
does come with um
we're packaging and selling deals
unfortunately
yes ma'am how are you doing jimmy jimmy
jimmy what's happening to samuel lives
really well buddy yeah really really
really well um what's happening how are
you doing what's going on your end
oh good man i'm excited about that
sounds sweet
i know i know i'm sensitive so listen
unfortunately
um i've got a little this is gonna
happen by the way oh
dude i'm so sorry i'm so sorry do you
know what
i was i said to laura and i was like
this is one of the absolute pains
that comes with deal sourcing
unfortunately the bungalow's fallen
through
um it absolutely sucks monkey poo and
obviously we're
we can we can refund you and everything
no problem um
it's just like so i was so devastated
because that was it was such a it was
such a peach
so i guess from your point of view i
mean whatever you want to do mate i mean
we can we can
i know you've paid 3500 as well which is
a nice which is a sweet fee it's not
it's not a small amount so we can
i mean we can we're not bothered about
i'd rather have the deal and the money
back but
i don't want just any old deal if you're
not i mean yeah yeah
what we can do we can put you as our
absolute number one
anything we look at that does juicy
we'll send it to you before we send it
to anybody um
and then in the next few weeks if it's
like this isn't really working out
we'll send you an email over now to sort
of say you know if you decide that now
these properties aren't appropriate um
regardless of how we feel about them
it's about how you feel and if you're
not like you know what that's a peach i
want it
then then we'll we'll refund you but
we'll we can we can we can keep trying
in the meantime because we are viewing a
lot
all right that's cool sorry it didn't
work out with the bungalow so um all
right and lauren will keep you posted
um and and if you need anything for me
just drop us a message
wicked all right lovely thanks so much
jimmy
cheers bye yes
see that's just the thing you just gotta
be quick and up front yeah he was
gutted wasn't he was he was he was he he
really liked that deal then he bought
these things just happened he really
likes that deal
but i think um you know what
i think you're finding something oh 100
what did you learn from that
well it was definitely awkward it was
definitely an awkward conversation to
have
yeah but i think the way that you
handled it you know it was a
it was a negative because as soon as he
picks up the phone he was like oh i'm
really excited about this deal and i was
just like oh
no we're about to tell him we haven't
got it it's gone
it's the way that you flipped it around
you know it was a negative thing you
flipped it to a positive
and it you just reminded him that like
look the money's not an issue like you
can have it
yeah like if you want the refund i'd do
it now yeah and it was him that was like
you know what no
but that's what if i'd have if i'd have
not done that if i'd have said to him
the deal fell through we'll find you
another one he'd been like no
no give my money back but because i went
deal's falling through it look we give
you money back
today immediately i can ping it over or
we have got some other juicy ones
give us a few weeks well and then he was
because he we put him in the position of
control
then he was like actually you know what
keep looking so we've got now
i said a few weeks so i've spoke to a
couple of investors
my ends yeah that want to meet you
okay you might know them all right i
told you i had money you can see the
cars now
hey how are you i've lived before
so you're looking to buy some houses
folks yeah let's do it so you want to
see some good
high cash flowing return on investment
properties around the manchester area
absolutely i like it right let's go
let's go let's go first property
the deals are so good we've got like
love island stars liv cook
i'm there with arsenal football players
ringing me up wanting me to show them
the property
it's like it's really tough
i don't know what how we're going to
handle this
half a million pounds i want but
once it's done the work's finished
you'll be with 865
conversion i'll split four flats full
refurb
i haven't got i've got viewing on it but
you can just walk around it and have a
look how many figures do we care about
when we're doing deals like this
three figures what do you mean there's
three things we're interested
it's a big one but you know what though
you always want us the same with any
industry you kind of want to build up to
stuff
what can i realistically start with
where i can get build my confidence get
my teeth into a project i can be proud
of
so after go looking at the other one i
feel like this is
[Music]
you got some real crackers today for us
bro yeah there's been some really good
ones today i'm really interested
especially about that last one
oh i think even if jordan and
liv don't buy these properties we'll
just email them out later we'll sell
them because they're really good deals
yeah
if jordan doesn't i know you're pushing
jordan a bit trying to get him to make a
decision and buy something that hmo
could be making him you know a thousand
a month the key is though with these
people is to not be pushy make them
make them want it yeah sometimes when
you're like not bothered you're like oh
well
you know other investors or email out
tonight it makes them want it more
than when you're trying to sell it to
them so you've seen quite a few houses
three different houses you know this
dude wants to make a sale
which one's your favorite which will be
your favorite option third one
sees so much potential like how it's
been looked after yeah
we did the numbers and the deal that the
deal with the estate agent sounded good
might have to choose any third one it
would be i think at this point
okay definitely well you know how we
work with with our sourcing business and
stuff
what would you need from what would you
need from lawton right now
in order to make a decision mainly just
sale price you know but apart from that
like yeah
well we've pretty much got the cell
phone secured aren't we at 190 yeah
yeah i mean after having a conversation
with you now and you're showing your
interest in it we can definitely have
give them another call tomorrow and get
them to agree the sale price for us
for sure in principle are you happy with
the numbers that we've shown you so far
in terms of like what
how much it's going to cost worst case
like the case and best case for the
refurb end value and then the rental all
those figures like look
good for you so far yeah i think you've
covered quite a lot you know um
and we've worked out you know best case
scenario worst case scenario and
yeah not really going to lose money yeah
i think so what i would say is then why
don't we go ahead with it
on that basis we'll get these surveys
and everything before of course before
you buy any property you're going to get
surveys
yeah and if anything happens or it goes
wrong when it falls out we'll replace it
with a suitable similar property amazing
yeah cool so confirm concern the sale
price
sort the underpinning and i'm in cool
100
yeah my guy good to see your business
i'm excited and hopefully we'll see uh
we'll see many more properties to come
yeah
i like the fact that obviously you
arranged for us to see three completely
different houses before because
before today coming in doing like the
research that i've done here and then
speaking to people that know that are in
property yeah like friends and just
people that i know in acquaintances yeah
my thought was i'll just get a hmo to be
solid investment a lot of my money will
be tied up in the hmo but then i'm
coming today
and i would have actually crunched the
numbers
which i learned how to do like from
today yeah i've been like
i'm gonna be better off being out in the
house and doing a brr
yeah refinancing it pulling my money out
yeah again yeah
i think that was just oh yeah it's just
opened my mind up to other opportunities
and i think we're spending the day with
some new guys proper experience i
know how to start to look out for that
so i'll be going home with flipping
right move on hi no it's okay
but the only thing i just want you to
understand is that like the terms the
terms and conditions are
always there to protect obviously myself
and the client
and then the only sort of issue that i
see with it is that it's all protecting
you
and then i'm sort of left
[Music]
you need to be high energy let's just if
she trusts you and she likes you she'll
buy
i got it okay
you have to be high energy and you have
to say i can't wait to meet you and go
around the property with you or do a
video you need to say that now not yet
let me listen cause she's running
through the teams
um
but i promise i know i've done this
hundreds of times
you need to change the way of the
conversation get away from the detail
right make it
about emotion and image i promise all
right
is if the deal falls through then
what we'll do is we'll replace the deal
for you for a like for like one
surely so i told him
so he's fine for me he was really kind
to giving the money back on the turkey
from
january yeah like we signed
three months but then i said god it's
not even my fault it was the vendors
like just two weeks three months
like um tell your caller back because i
need to spend a minute with you because
i promise
i i'd have a closed in one minute i
can't even take over if you want take a
look let me check it out
back and forth back and forth
yeah yeah
oh my goodness it's graziella what's
happening
with me
lauren told me very different lauren
told me that you're an absolutely
amazing person
so oh i'm so glad you guys connected
that i'm so glad you guys connected
after the call
i mean here the thing is the thing is
graziella like
ultimately i know we've got a contract
in place to make sure that
things are done properly but ultimately
like
all we want is you to be happy you need
to have a good deal and if it came to it
if you weren't going to be happy and you
were upset
and the deal fell through lawton
wouldn't hesitate to give you a free a
full refund it's just a case of
the contract's there to just protect and
make sure everything's done fairly in
that but
the most important thing for lawton and
for myself is just that you're happy
we'll send the email out in the next
five or ten minutes all right
speak soon thank you speak to you soon
bye
what do you think what's funny you're
just you're good at the way that you
speak to her
you are good at the way he's beat
somewhere well like for me
it was like pushed down and pushed down
because like i've been dealing
over like you were at the end of your
tether yeah i was like
what is going on like the terms and
conditions are the terms and conditions
and now the terms conditions she wants
them all to be all one-sided and i'm
like i don't think they're alone
but i think the answer well from that
conversation which is that then
she has changed and adapted it within
the like and then i was like
i know yeah this is what i was saying
that like yeah yesterday
but you were saying it yesterday but you
were saying in a different way you
needed to put your arm around her yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah i'm so
glad that i jumped in oh yeah me too
i've just had someone come through
oh my god i've been waiting for it for
so long
another 2k in the bank getting quite
good at this now aren't you
we're getting there we are getting there
i think i can hear him
on the phone now it sounds like he's
secure more deals let's go and see what
he's up to
but you get a lot of calls coming in a
couple of messages yeah yeah five or six
um what's happening with that bundler so
the bungalow has now officially had the
offer accepts on it which is good
but now pressing from us to the um proof
of funds and everything you definitely
don't want to sell that
do you no i don't want to keep it you
want that bungalow yeah massively
because there's too much in it if we can
like do it up like some of the ones that
are on that street you know it's going
to be worth a fortune
yeah do you reckon we can make about how
much profit on that 100 grand
between 1800 grand yeah yeah well we can
get the money
john can give you the the deposit 70
grand
yeah no he said no no but he doesn't
want to come on it as a joint event he
just wants to loan the money
because he's coming out of like it's
kind of like expansion possibly he
doesn't want to be a part of the deal
it's 14 yeah so you need to be able to
get the other money you just get more
so i still need to really find a tv
partner for it because i've
found the deal i've found somebody wants
to put the money in but then i still
need
a jv partner to um help with the
mortgage side of it
yeah so i won't be able to get the
mortgage on it because i've got i was
made redundant so there's no been
there's there hasn't been any lights off
paces or anything nasty for the past few
months
so you won't get a mortgage right now
why um so what do you want from me
well if you think the deal's good enough
yeah i'd be up he says look at
having a conversation with you see if
you watch it coming on with us
i don't really deal with that side of
the things than on the business but i
can speak to my wife
yeah well i mean there's there's money
in it like once it's gonna be first
i'm being [ __ ] i'm joking
i'm joking there's money in it
especially like if we were to refinance
at the end after
it works yeah or we could just sell it
and just flip it so three options
so basically you want to set up a
company with me
and go or have a 50 50 deal yeah you
want me to get a mortgage on it
and then i'll do all the work on it i'll
do all the development work and i'll
oversee the whole thing i'm generally
excited now
you don't even need to see it let me
ring um let me and my wifey and just say
how she feels about doing a joint
venture with um
we've i think i taught you a little bit
too well though mate now quick question
so lauren's got this little bungalow
we've agreed to buy 475 grand
the end value is going to be about 400
grand
we're going to extend it turn it into a
four bed it's currently a two bed
bungalow
needs about 50 grand on it 35 grand for
the extension plus maybe 15 20 grand for
the
conversion it's decently it'll be our
ideal seasonal project
however he hasn't got accompanied set up
in finance behind him he can't get a
mortgage literally nothing
we've got someone that will put 70 grand
in he's wondering whoever will come in
on the deal
not put money into it but just sit on
the company to be able to then get a
mortgage on it and be able to get all
the finance behind it any bridging that
we need
so the question is how do you fancy
taking on a little bungalow
in manchester into our portfolio
sounds cool but i'd like to see it first
if possible
would you want to speak to him sure hey
amanda it's just me
hey hey no no we can definitely get sort
of like a viewing on it and then
show you around and show you the vision
of it and then we're about to get on the
inside though but we'll be able to go
around the outside but to be honest yeah
it's a development opportunity i don't
think we need to go in it yeah but
you'll be able to sort of see this
yeah i know you'll be able to sort of
see the scope of it and then in fact
there's actually like a property that's
next door that's sort of done the vision
of what we're sort of suggesting
and there's his work there's his work
like four look at that one as well
[Laughter]
[Music]
come now tomorrow well that looks good
and we'll see if we can get it in the
bag as a jv with us on the norton
cool okay all right sweet party tomorrow
see you later
i'll text you the address i'll text the
address we went from
wanting to be go from debt to
financially free now it's no i want to
get rid of my debt i want to be debt
free and then i want to be a
full-time developer yeah it's the it's
not the financial freedom challenge it's
the become a developer
from nothing challenge yeah yeah yeah
that's cool man we can do
what are we going what are we going to
look at some of the opportunities that
you've got that lined up in the
development stuff because now i feel
like
now you've made some money for packaging
selling deals and you've got a bit of
money in
hopefully the clouds begin to disappear
a little bit
this is a little bit bigger than we are
than we started off yeah definitely you
might not rent to rent you want to buy
land instead yeah i just want to go
straight into development okay so what's
he saying
what's the guy say so this is up for
sale for 450 the land at a minute it
comes with planning permission for six
luxury town houses i know it's six six
six six stand out so there's two at the
front
yeah in a gated community and there's
four at the back okay cool it's nice
it is there's a lot of work that he's
doing to the actual language right this
ground is not level
no not at all he's leveling it is
leveling so
what what do you think we're gonna do
with this and how how soon can we meet
the owner and figure out what's what
well i mean we need to get on the phone
because we obviously want to get a
meeting with him
this week um so i'm pretty confident we
can do that we've built some good
rapport with him
and but yeah six luxury townhouses this
is gonna be really really good so my
thing
is we need to get david down the
architect yes get a quote on what how
much it's gonna cost to build
we need to obviously meet the owner have
a face-to-face with him and uh we
i don't know where you're gonna get the
money from i'm not putting the money
into that
i'm not putting nobody into this i mean
it's all for sale so
you know we'll have a conversation if
the deal is good we can find the joint
venture back of course
of course the deal's good we can find
the joint venture partner
hey here's amanda hi
the decision maker how are you doing
you're right i'm good how are you
so you need to you need to you need to
sell it to amanda now then so that's
good
no problem so as you can see this is the
bungalow that we've got
okay and we've actually secured this for
275 which is
amazing what we need to do is we need to
spend about 50k on it
okay to do it up and then we should be
achieving a price of like
400 grand wow and the reason why we know
that is because this one over there
has actually been sold last month for
400 000
and that's been refurbed as well okay so
what we're gonna do with this one we're
gonna turn this one into a four bed
detached bungalow right so guys you
extend it at the back
and lift it up okay
sounds interesting 50k just for the
extension
so 35k for the extension and then about
15 20 grand
for the refurb inside the existing
bundle we've already had that quote from
an actual architect as well
okay i'd love to know like how what the
area is because they
35 for the extension sounds light you've
also got to remember we are up in the
north as well so that's true maybe
comparing it to prices down south yeah
up here but we have had a ballpoint
figure for it okay
cool i'll show you oh yeah come on
so now we're around the back of it this
is probably where we would have the
extension done
okay why not at the front
well we could we have got the option
because it's corner plot we've got land
all around it so we could
but speaking to our builder he did
suggest coming this way but again that
can change because the plans haven't
been drawn yet
but the builders who have been speaking
to builders that you've used before as
well which is
i think is a really good move okay okay
what's the inside like the inside's in
really good condition to be fair it's
not in a bad way is that so
in terms of the refurb on the inside
it's really just going to be
uh that new kitchen bathroom ensuite or
whatever
i don't know yeah if you're going to try
and sell it for 400
yeah yeah yeah why don't you show around
the other one yeah
you can visualize what it will look like
it's so
modern yeah so what it looks like it
looks like they've brought this bit out
and they've made their own
hallway here and they've gone up a level
and right across at the back as well but
if we walk around
the outside this way we can see where
the staircase is which is really nice
so that's nice look can you see the
glass oh my gosh yeah
you use this as a benchmark and you can
just tweak it
on the other one to make it even nicer
yeah so what did you think of it then
i think it sounds i think it sounds good
i think i just need to sort of mull over
the figures a little bit yeah
so i'd love to speak to david the
architect rather than even mull over the
figures i think what amanda wants to do
she wants to know the figures are legit
if you knew what the figures were
exactly you had everything in front of
you you'd make a decision on the spot
wouldn't you yeah
and listen the only reason i'm bringing
a man into this is because she's my wife
she's a qs
this will be our personal pro you know
what i mean i mean this is a
i don't want to just be like oh just
because i'm doing the challenge with
lauren i'll do it
i want to make sure that this is
actually a viable good decision for us
as a business
yeah you know so we're actually meeting
david later so you can
speak to him about the build costs and
everything okay and maybe that might
give you some more confidence in
actually what we're planning on doing
with it you know over there
cool once i've spoken with him i'll give
you a decision then
by the end of the day by the end of the
day
[Music]
david what's happening
thank you so much for coming out is that
your notice
thank you so this is lawton i think you
know obviously you know amanda
how you doing so um so yeah basically
i'll kind of show you around
give your low down and then hopefully
you'll be able to give us an answer
pretty quick about what you're thinking
okay and then we'll let you guys know in
a couple minutes it's a nice little deal
yeah it is because it's not that bad
condition
no and there's not looking at there's
not major things you need to do to it so
would you just extend it this side or
would you do at the back as well or what
i don't look at the numbers really if if
again if you're getting more value banks
then at the back
yeah i would do that but if you're just
going to gain the most value by going
sideways and not doing the back because
you're getting the floor area
yeah i won't even touch it and then
probably look at doing something in the
loft
getting a bit of space upstairs yeah if
it stairs uh
again you might not need to do that to
get the uplift because obviously
you're looking for a ceiling product
yeah it's a saving price and also it's
just return
the profit of what you should we see
what they've done on this one you have a
look at it
all they've done is done cheap planning
on the outside
it's not even the best planet do you
think it has to be a lot better oh yeah
definitely
how much money do you reckon it would
cost to get
that one like this one
um it's the same level same level
extension wise yeah
uh cladding from it's only gonna really
cost you around about thirty five
thousand that's we're doing right
because that's brilliant it's not a
massive extension it's a single story
i'm so glad that you've said that and
you've actually seen it and stuff and
then obviously the inside might be
we've budgeted about 15 grand for the
inside so
our 50 grand estimate do you think
you're pretty spot on that so let's tell
lauren should we wind him up though and
tell him it's going to be 80 grams yeah
definitely i want to see his face i want
to see what happens
yeah so you're looking for the outside
to be about 60 don't you
yeah which is more than we thought but
it could still work it's just less
profit than we thought
i'm very confident on the end value of
240
275 plus 80. that's three five hours
there's still 45
grand profit in it but if you refinance
it probably we're borrowing money as
well to do it so we'll tell you about
the bridging off there's no profit in it
no at least you've got that land deal
to look at next we're just wondering if
it's 35.
15 for the inside 50 grand
so does that mean we have a deal yeah
oh my god thank you
and he's you want to take on the work
yeah yeah committee development
refinance pull your money out 50 50
partnership
dude offer accepted you're going to be a
property owner
in a couple weeks a couple months we'll
see how long it is
nice one how you feeling about the
bungalow excited
excited yeah okay so right now we've got
a piece of land to go and look at okay
in fact we've already viewed the land
i've spoke to david about it five houses
we're gonna build from scratch
there's about half a million pound
profit in there the only thing is
the guy that's selling the land what's
450 grand what i'm thinking is
i'm going to get lawton to go in with
david who's got a building company
and try and get a deal and i'm thinking
they could jv
with the owner and get the owner to
donate the land
to let them have the land get paid for
it later
plus get a slice of the profit because
the owner doesn't need the money we
spoke to him on the phone
so i'm reckoning now lauren's confidence
is up on this deal
i'm thinking that momentum is going to
stop building now yeah but i'm really i
think he's going to be a really
successful property developer
i think so so i'm really excited i think
that really excites him yeah
so i'm going to have a chat okay so this
is the land yep
we've got planning permission already
for six houses yeah he wants 450 for it
yeah but what i'm thinking is we're
thinking if
he could come in on the deal yeah take a
slice of the profits
yeah we've got a meeting with him in
like oh it's about
about 45 minutes about 45 minutes yeah
what do you think of the deal
yeah it's just a good deal obviously
depending on how much you pay for it and
then joe ventures well
we don't want to pay anything yeah this
will be his deal in fact i don't even
think i need to come in on the meeting
i think you guys go to the meeting now
do your thing
yeah and see what you can do yeah yeah i
agree yeah perfect all right all right
so you think that amanda is really happy
with the dylan's jack jerking she's it
she isn't
she's gone home she's done it's him
oh my god i'm so stoked oh you really
yeah it's actually i'm
actually i own a freaking bungalow
obviously don't
own it yet but yeah it's in the bag it's
done no money down bungalow
lawn developer in less than a week
today's about the seventh day and dude
it might be that we secure this next
deal
i know and then that's going to be that
this is going to be what pieces are
under six houses
yeah how much how much of the house is
gonna be worth what's the belt if we can
put it off
um two mil yeah the total gd about 2.2
million cool
so what do you need for me then for this
next thing because i'm not sitting
tonight so do you think it's a good idea
if you
to not come in do i mean because i think
like with it being such a big meeting
like yeah you being there i i just feel
like you don't need me
in there especially if david's going to
be in on the meeting there's like three
of us
you've done one development deal already
i don't think you need me in there
i think i think you're good i think now
you can start standing on your own two
feet
and i want you to know after this week
that you can continue getting deals
again and again and again
you don't need me in every meeting it's
the seventh day today obviously when i
first found this deal
i thought how am i gonna negotiate the
price of it yeah should i mean i didn't
think that maybe
we could use him to bring in the ladder
it's all about doing it as a no money
down deal
that would be no money down on it yes if
he's supplying the land yeah
get development finance you've spoke to
him already right yeah
and he's flexible open he doesn't need
the money now no
yeah dude if we can pull this off
this is going to be massive this is
unlike any financial freedom challenge
i've ever done
this is insane
oh my god so it's bang on
good luck
i feel a bit sick to be fair yeah we
don't get anything to lose
i know i know i know and that's the way
i'm looking at it because like this
opportunity if we if i can get on with
this person and get this deal to build
these six houses like this is
like the the dream journey to be a
property developer
yeah go on before you like good luck all
right i'll chat you in a bit okay
he is so nervous why
he looks like it's his first day at
school so basically he's going to be
going in
and um what do you reckon amelia what
are you thinking
i think he'll do it it's not like how we
have spoke to him on the phone
before um we know the situation with the
he doesn't the guy who's got the land
doesn't need the cash for the land
so it makes sense for him to just donate
the land
and get the money later in with the
profits plus he'll get more money
so yeah there he is oh he's smiling
no money down money power six houses
how do you feel i don't even know like
my heart is just like
pounding oh just need a minute just to
like i'm just gonna
i just need a minute to chill honestly
dude honestly well done mate it was a
good meeting as well it was just nice so
what are the figures what's happening
well he's putting in advance it's 1.3 to
build
how are you gonna how are you gonna get
the money to build bridge development
finance on it
no money down no money down at all
getting to heaven on the deal yeah
all night and then we're gonna do a 50
50 on the profit share on the end how
much will you make on the deal
oh well i mean we need to discuss it
with the other people that are involved
in it
me and david but it's going to be like
an olympic grand
you're a property developer bro
it's unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable are we done
i think we need to tell rachel have you
told her anything no
why don't we meet rachel at the bungalow
and be like and also elsa
have you got money in your bank how much
money driving you back how much money
have we made from deal something
you've done for nine grand so far
nine grand cash in the bank
in the bank yeah another two coming
that's been confirmed
eleven grand rachel has no idea
let's me ready let's meet with one of
the developments of the bungalow and be
like hey baby hey wherever you know that
house
that big nice bungalow that's mine also
we're not in debt anymore you see that
nine grand
oh and on top of that you want to come
and see a piece of land we brought in
six houses
let's go man text text to the address of
the bungalow let's go
oh my god oh yes
so this week i've made eleven thousand
pound cash in the bank from deal
sourcing
i've secured this bungalow on a joint
venture
development and i've also secured a
piece of land with planning permission
for six houses
my mind has absolutely just blown this
week it's been unbelievable
and i'm stood out outside there waiting
for rachel to come with macy
to show them our new place
hello how you doing
it's been a bit of a crazy week
and what we've done is we've made
a little bit of money on the deal
sourcing
but we're definitely debt free now
because we made it over 11 000 pounds
in deal selling
is that sure that's mine that's all mine
and then we've also bought this house
we've bought this bungalow this isn't
gonna cost us anything
to get into it we've got somebody
funding it
samuel's jumping in on it so when we
actually do this up we're gonna make
about
probably about 60 to 80 grand on this
development deal there's gonna be like
over 120 grand
to be made on that
you know maybe all right you've never
seen daddy cry have you ever
what do you think makes
you like this
[Music]
thank you so much appreciate you coming
up it's been awesome like it's just
life-changing having you here and just
culturing us through it well guys
honestly
great job and uh i guess i'll see you
again soon yeah you need anything give
me
your time right thank you so much
you're so welcome honestly i'm feeling
quite emotional
i think it's like it's such a good
feeling
he started with less than nothing
um really really proud of him
yeah can you move into my house next
[Music]
you